[Music]
[Music]
i see the crystal raindrops fall
and the beauty of it all is when the
moon comes shining through
[Music]
to make those cobwebs in my mind when i
think of you sometimes and i want to
spend it with you
just the two of us
we can
[Music]
you and i
[Music]
we are together you and i oh how quickly
the time flies i wish nothing would
the change of us
we can make it if we try just the two of
us
[Music]
just the three of us
we can make it if we try just the three
of us
you you and i
cause the three of us
the three of us
that's right just the three of us
we can make it if we try yes the three
of us
here's to hotel transylvania
on january 14th family movie night is
getting revamped only on prime video
for centuries no human has had the power
to become a monster
until now
but is this safe though let's find
[Music]
is out okay down here hey drac what's up
oops
what's going on i used van helsing's
transforming ring
you're human drag dad
oh no i have a total dad bod
um what is going on
[Music]
what's up
[Music]
who are those guys it's me uncle griffin
you don't recognize me i've literally
never seen you before
there is a place deep in the amazon only
there can the transformations be
reversed time to go
stereo
if we don't fix you guys through you'll
be like this forever
being a human is the worst
mosquito
hotel transylvania transfer mania
boy that was fun
ready pg coming january 14th only on
prime video
[Music]
bye